though he's no stranger to television
you probably recognize American actor
David Harbor as stranger things
chain-smoking lawman chief hopper his
character in the hit Netflix series is a
hero of sorts but not exactly a
superhero there's one comics derived
role that's perfect for him though the
cigar-smoking half-demon hero Hellboy
since the first image of Harbor is
Hellboy for the upcoming reboot went
live the internet has buzzed with
conjecture as to how stranger things
soft Sheriff got so swole well wonder no
longer here's how harbor shed that extra
weight and put on some powerful red
muscle workout blues prior to landing
the Hellboy reboot david harbors
relationship with the gym wasn't
particularly close in fact it was
virtually non-existent a fact
unsurprising to anyone who's ever seen
chief hopper washing down his Monday
morning medication with last night's
beer and eating donuts for breakfast in
an interview on his trainers official
website harbor explained I was a chubby
kid growing up straight out of college I
did my first play which I got pretty in
shape for but I let that go completely
so from about the time I was 26 years
old to about now I haven't really been
training at the gym seriously at all
Harbor is now in his 40s but he's proven
that it's never too late to get back in
shape
superhero trainer going from playing a
police chief with a beer belly to a
jacked-up half-demon superhero is no
easy feat and probably one harbor
couldn't accomplish by himself in order
to go from big softie to brother red he
enlisted the help of one of Hollywood's
biggest names in the training biz Don
Saladino Saladin owes client list is
extensive and includes superhero actors
like Sebastian Stan and Ryan Reynolds
among others as harbor explained there's
something very special about Don as a
person and a trainer he brings great
creativity to the workout regimes which
in the past have usually terrified and
bored me his methods are unique as well
as heavily researched not only that but
they are even fun despite the challenges
you're taking on boot camp as is often
the case with big-name superheroes David
Harbor needed to get into Hellboy shape
in a very short period of time thanks to
Don Saladin O's official Instagram we
know he put harbor through a rigorous
10-week boot camp and that was just to
kick things off Saladino said getting
David ready for this role was an
absolute blasphemy the sessions weren't
easy but like all of my clients I made
sure that he felt great at the end of
every day by the end he not
only put on some real muscle but also
was more flexible than ever
as for harbor well his goals were a
little more down-to-earth I'd like to
discover that I have abs even if those
abs are a bit fleshy secret weapon in an
interview with the New York Post
Saladino laid out the tailored regimen
that took Harbor from hopper to Hellboy
first they increased the frequency of
his workouts to five to six days a week
in the nine weeks before Hellboy but the
real key to success Saladino revealed is
a move he calls the suitcase carry
according to the all-star trainer this
workout hits nearly every muscle group
in the body from the glutes to the
biceps though it may sound grueling
Saladino says harbor never complained
about anything and that he just loved
how strong he was kidding hey who
wouldn't
scary strength most superhero actors
training for the big screen are not only
trying to get ripped they're trying to
look good doing it David Harbor he
trained to get scary and in order to
look scary he had to look strong really
strong we didn't want like an
Abercrombie like a ripped out you needed
to look like scary Harbor agreed saying
in terms of Hellboy like he's a big
demon monster but he really knows how to
fight I did want to develop mainly power
and strength so that when I'm doing
these movements and doing this role that
you believe it like you believe that
this guy when he hits you hits you like
a truck he stays motivated as any actor
who's ever embarked on a superhero
training regimen will tell you
motivation is key David Harbour found
motivation through the people who will
flock to theaters to see the Hellboy
reboot the fans are what are keeping me
motivated through everything as well as
the audience that will come see the
movie and the haters out there who have
decided to make their opinion known
before a scene has even been shot I've
got something to prove to all three I
really want to do justice to this
character and create a Hellboy that
everyone can get behind room to grow
despite his intense 10-week boot camp
with one of Hollywood's most in-demand
trainers David Harbour isn't actually
getting as big as you might think
in fact as you may have guessed from the
first images of the actor as Hellboy
he's actually wearing a bodysuit Harbor
went on live with Kelly and Ryan to
explain his dismay at not being able to
post Instagram selfies like his other
superhero cohorts well no so the thing
is I thought well here we go like I get
to do a superhero movie
I'm gonna do that Chris Pratt thing
where you buff out and take selfies in
front of the mirrors and the producers
are now like if you lose weight you're
not gonna fit in the suit the upshot
barber is working out but he also gets
to eat all the junk food he wants sure
beats whatever Chris Pratt's been eating
no matter how many Instagram selfies he
gets to take thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love too
[Music]